Merci.
Mon système de neurones miroirs suggère que cela va remplacer les téléphones
dans peu de temps.
Ray, comment ça va ?
Ray : Très bien. Nous sommes en direct aujourd'hui.
(Applaudissements)
MG: Ray, donne au public un cadeau
du cerveau holographique que nous avons vu plus tôt.
Ceci va non seulement remplacer les téléphones,
mais cela va changer également notre manière de collaborer.
Merci beaucoup.
Merci, Ray.
Ray : De rien.
(Applaudissements)
MG: Bon, voici le message que j'ai découvert dans un bar en 2011 :
le futur des ordinateurs n'est pas bloqué à l'intérieur de l'un de ces écrans.
Il est juste là, en nous.
(Applaudissements)
S'il n'y a qu'une seule idée que je peux donner aujourd'hui,
c'est que la machine naturelle n'est pas le fruit du futur,
elle est juste ici en 2016.
C'est pourquoi nous tous à Meta,
incluant le personnel administratif,
les cadres,
les designers, les ingénieurs --
avant TED2017,
nous allons tous mettre à la poubelle nos moniteurs externes
et les remplacer par des machines vraiment et profondément plus naturelles.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)
Merci, c'est très gentil.
Merci à tous.
Chris Anderson : Bon, expliquez-moi une chose,
parce qu'il y a eu peu de démonstrations sur la réalité augmentée
l'année dernière ou précédemment ici-même.
Et il y a parfois un débat parmi les technologistes
pour savoir si nous voyons vraiment l'objet réel à l'écran.
C'est un problème de champ de vision.
D'une certaine manière, la technologie montre une vue plus large
que celle que vous devriez voir en portant les lunettes.
Avons-nous vu la vraie vie ?
MG : Absolument la vraie vie.
Et pas seulement cela,
nous avons pris d'autres mesures pour filmer avec une GoPro
avec les vraies lentilles, les différentes vidéos diffusées.
Nous voulons essayer de simuler l'expérience du monde
que nous voyons à travers les lunettes,
et ne couper aucun passage.
CA : Merci beaucoup pour cette présentation.
MG : Merci beaucoup, c'était un plaisir.